all right six one seven eight three zero
4750 let's take our next caller from the
nine seven eight area code an area code
very familiar to us here on the show
caller what's your name and where are
you calling from my name is Skyler and
I'm calling from Fitchburg Massachusetts
all right Fitchburg I've been to
Fitchburg before Fitchburg I don't have
that much to say about it but it's I've
been there what's on your mind there's
not much to say
I kind of have two questions the first
question is I'm just getting so wrapped
up in all of this Trump whatever that
it's like making me viscerally angry and
I'm just when especially the the the the
money that is spent for these trips to
Mara Lago and like 300 Secret Service
men I mean really and I'm wondering how
does it stop like is this gonna stop no
ken is there anybody in yeah there's
nobody who's gonna be Sean Spicer said
when he was asked now that he would not
expect the Mara Lago trips to be
curtailed anytime soon so I think you
know I understand the visceral reaction
to what's going on Skylar but I think
that I I would maybe focus on something
other than the Mara Lago trip stopping
because I don't think that's a good if
you're if you're looking to be
viscerally relieved from bad feelings by
the Mara Lago trip sobbing it's not
happening Sean Spicer was even asked
what the difference was between Trump
golfing all the time and Obama golfing
all the time and he said that well when
Trump does it he's meeting with other
dignitaries he's having these
conversation and he's still working as
if Obama wasn't doing that the whole
time right Obama was just golfing when
he was developing what was what was your
second question Skylar
my second question is do you have a
family member who is a trumpet and if so
how do you deal with them okay Pat is
already cringing my answer is no because
most of my family is not in the US my
family is in basically mostly in
Argentina and then some in Spain France
and Israel so I don't have any family
member that are trumpets however I'm
gonna turn over the floor to producer
Patrick Constantine Ford well okay so
first off to Massachusetts Republicans
which as you know is kind of like
Republican light so it's not as big of a
deal as if they were in Mississippi or
something they reluctantly got behind
Trump because they considered him to be
the lesser of two evils compared to
Hillary Clinton but yes unfortunately
there's a lot of trumpets in my family
and we have discussions on the issues
and I think that's where you should keep
it rather than just the antics that are
going on but it's tough to deal with it
you gotta love them no matter what right
yeah yeah yeah unfortunately no it's
actually my dad and he's in New
Hampshire so okay all right listen sky
law has been a real pleasure and it's
always great to hear from people in the
great Commonwealth of Massachusetts and
appreciate the call thank you so much
you're welcome take care all right